le délai
l'hôtel date dont à l'ouest du
centre-ville est bien vivant pour un
hôtel construit en 1881 c'est soir de
vernissage le gladstone a invité 40
artistes aux torontois a présenté des
oeuvres des installations il y en a aux
quatre étages le gladstone
cl krisztina than le artistes visuels
cinéaste et président de l'hôtel
le gladstone a connu jadis ses heures de
gloire comme hôtel de gare mais ensuite
il est tombé en désuétude occupés par
des chambreurs jusqu'en 2003 où entre en
scène et berra et christine à z le père
et fille le projet de sauver l'hôtel et
d'en faire un repaire d'artistes c'est
l'idée de la fille l'argent pour acheter
l'hôtel c'est le père aujourd'hui âgé de
90 ans quoi d'autre at il acheté ce
monsieur est de ceux-ci une gigantesque
usine désaffectée en plein centre ville
de toronto le 4 sans richmond hd pour
qui son autre fille margaret zain
1998 l'édifice allait être rasé pour
faire place à un parking elle aussi
amoureuse de bâtiments patrimoniaux
margaret chan le convainc son père
d'acheter l'immeuble pour un million et
demi on les disait fou et pourtant ils
ont réussi le 408 ch menait devenue un
repaire d'artistes
l'immeuble a été convertie est divisé en
une centaine d'ateliers galerie et
bureaux
l'idée offrira des artistes comme line
christine télé des locaux au centre
ville au plus bas coût possible
elle paie un loyer de 1000 $ par mois
linn kristin calais a de l'espace pour
travailler et être entouré d'artistes à
toronto
l'immobilier est tellement cher que bien
des artistes sont chassées de la ville
est trop cher
une alternative à une heure de là à
milton dans une autre usine désaffectée
ça ça ira original et regarder qui est
la serrure à blaye l'heure il est le
frère de christina et de margaret ce
qu'elle lui aussi thavasa et de lui
acheter un bâtiment patrimonial la
cantine factory une ancienne usine de
textile et rob zombie est en train de la
transformer en ateliers d'artistes
exactement comme l'a fait sa soeur à
toronto ce studio est louée 250 dollars
par mois et montano c'est super pour les
artistes parce qu'il ya la possibilité
de louer ou acheter un studio ici à
toronto dès les prix sont incroyables
voyez cette immense atelier loué par
scott bolton qui se spécialise dans le
lettrage dans cinq dessinés à la main
ils paient 1400 $ par mois pour 1600
pieds cave et scott martin adore le prix
et l'ambiance qui règne mais qui ce père
qui met tout son argent au service de
ses enfants et de l'art et des retraites
le est un grand architecte qui a réalisé
des dizaines de projets à toronto comme
le centre eaton ou alors la
transformation d'un immense terminal en
un complexe avec bureaux commerces
condos théâtre sur cette murale au 408
ch mène on voit une femme qui a eu une
grande influence à la fois sur berra
trailer et sur ses enfants
c'est la célèbre urbanistes jane jekabs
elle était une amie proche des red le
une femme qui a milité en faveur de la
diversité et la vivacité des villes
une de ces phrases célèbres les idées
nouvelles ont besoin de vieux édifices
et des dieux comme jane jacobs pense que
la ville
c'est une chose merveilleuse idée folle
un impair unique ses enfants disent de
lui qu'il est sans peur il aime prendre
des risques
son amour de l'art lui vient peut-être
aussi un peu de ses origines allemands
et ils pensent qu'à un européen il
il connaît l'importance de larmes ou
alors simplement dit l'aîné il y faut
que six crise et un père assez fou pour
soutenir sa fille qui fait décorer les
37 chambres de son hôtel par 37 artistes
différents assez fous pour acheter deux
anciennes usines pour que des dizaines
d'artistes puissent exercer leur à un
coût raisonnable
un père fou de sa progéniture
d'architecturé
et culture